aquí de nuevo hay una variedad de
opiniones porque la gran mayoría de
países europeos insisten en que hay que
confiar en la vacunación en esta dosis
de refuerzo a la población general
cuanto antes antes de que sigan
aumentando los casos pero aún así muchos
creen que también es necesario la
coordinación no ha sentado nada bien a
muchos países que italia haya tomado de
forma unilateral que se tenga que
aplicar tés tan negativos a la entrada
en el país e incluso a los pasajeros
vacunados europeos no ha sentado bien
que haya tomado esta forma esta medida
de forma unilateral sin coordinarse con
el resto de países por ello todos
quieren insistir en que también es
necesario coordinarse que estas medidas
unilaterales no funcionan y pueden poner
en riesgo el mercado único' europa se
encuentra con un gran aumento de
contagio de contagios por parte de
omicron por ello se va a insistir en la
importancia de la vacunación que las
vacunas funcionan y más aún cuando
omicron se va a convertir en una
variante dominante ya a mediados de
enero en todo